we'll talk about adding insult to injury
every morning thousands of nevadans are
waking up to look at their unemployment
portal trying to figure out
if they had their claim processed and we
know that many of you are scraping by as
you wait for those benefits joe moeller
shares one woman's story tonight
we have shared a lot of stories about
people who are struggling to get by as
they wait for their unemployment
benefits
today we came to east las vegas to speak
to a woman who was getting desperate for
answers regarding her claim as she
continues
to live in her brother's garage
unfortunately right now i stay
in his garage with my puppy i don't have
a bathroom
i don't have a kitchen this is nyree
mcgee
it's a little hard excuse me it's just
it's different for me i'm 28
you know i've always worked i've never
been on welfare
unemployment she says she has to live in
this garage as she waits for answers
regarding her unemployment benefits
this month be nine months on the fourth
it was nine months
nine months no pay she says she worked
at a beauty supply store that was forced
to close due to the pandemic
right now she relies on her mom who
lives in another state
my mom she's like my rock she helps me
out as best she can
she told us she sent in paperwork that
was asked from her twice
and has one pending resolution they
asked again in
august and i also provided that to them
too
and it's just been pending i've called i
talked to
customer service reps for dieter and
they have
just let me know to just wait she is
hoping to find another place to live
once she gets some benefits
after contracting covet herself earlier
in the fall she said her job search has
not been easy
nine months after filing she still
checks online frequently
every other day yeah every other day
praying to god that it changes or they
set an interview for me to speak with
someone
mcgee says she will continue to look for
a job and all she can do
right now is wait and just keep checking
her portal reporting in east las vegas
joe moller 8 news now
wow she is incredibly patient and many
of you have been wondering about
the lost wages assistance as well well
today dieter told us week five is still
being paid out and could take
another 10 days